todos los vídeos anteriores estuvimos
suponiendo una economía ideal que es la
competencia perfecta la competencia
perfecta y la competencia perfecta es
exactamente lo que piensas que es pero
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar más en esto con unos términos
exactos en términos de lo que son las
reglas básicas que necesitamos para
tener realmente una competencia perfecta
y es importante darse cuenta que hay
muchos mercados que son ciertamente con
perfectamente competitivos y estos son
muy buenos para los consumidores pero a
la vez están muy cerca de ser
competencia perfecta y si tenemos tiempo
vamos a discutir todo en el transcurso
del vídeo ahora para hacer perfectamente
competitivo tendrás que tener muchos
competidores entonces la primera
estipulación sería que tenemos que tener
muchos competidores y necesitan estar
compitiendo por ser el rey de los mismos
compradores y ofreciendo a la vez los
mismos productos
productos idénticos productos idénticos
y recuerda que estamos hablando de una
economía ideal aquí y hay muchos
mercados donde los productos son
absolutamente idénticos o el servicio es
absolutamente idéntico
pues estamos hablando de una economía y
del ideal aquí y la siguiente condición
va a ser que no vamos a tener barreras
para poder entrar sin barreras para
entrar así que en cualquier momento si
esto es atractivo para la gente puede
entrar al mercado y muchas personas van
a querer estar entrando a dicho mercado
y no debe de haber nada que los detenga
y si las compañías que ya están en el
mercado están haciendo ganancia
económica lo cual significa que es muy
bueno y lo cual entonces es una
excelente oportunidad para la gente para
poder entrar y generar un gran costo de
oportunidad y así mucha más gente quiera
entrar al mercado ahora encima de esto
no debe haber una ventaja nada de
ventajas para las empresas establecidas
no ventajas para las empresas existentes
así que una vez que alguien brinca o
entra al mercado
poniendo que son alguien realmente
competente ellos van a estar listos para
competir con los mismos términos para
que ganen a la gente que ya estaba ahí y
el último punto y muy importante es que
debes de tener una muy buena información
acerca del precio tal vez los
compradores y vendedores todos sepan
dichos precios pero los compradores
necesitan saber todos los precios de
todo el mercado pues ellos realmente
necesitan poder comparar y realizar sus
compras en base a esto los vendedores
necesitan saber cuándo hay un precio
demasiado bajo o bueno y ajustar sus
precios a estas nuevas tendencias así
que sería bueno que tuvieras buena
información de tu precio ahora bien hay
muchos tipos de mercados que son algo
aproximados a la competencia perfecta
hay tantos que son como competencia
perfecta pero uno de ellos que me viene
a la mente es definitivamente la
industria de las aerolíneas en méxico y
en nuestro primer punto pues hay muchas
pero muchas aerolíneas diferentes
entonces cumple con lo primero pero sin
embargo ellos no ofrecen productos
idénticos y esto seguro de las
aerolíneas no no estás tan de acuerdo
ellos dicen ser y tener diferencias en
cuanto al servicio y en cuanto al tipo
de comida por ejemplo que están dando y
no sé quizás en cuanto al peso del
equipaje durante el abordaje y todo lo
demás pero para la mayoría de los
consumidores esto solo luce como yo por
ejemplo si quiero un boleto económico
para viajar del df a cancún y ellos son
ofrecían diferentes productos más bien
idénticos productos esto haría la
industria de las aerolíneas lo bastante
buena para cumplir con el primer punto
ahora yendo al segundo punto no barreras
para entrar
bueno pues sabemos que si existen
barreras para entrar por ejemplo es
demasiado caro poderte introducir en el
mercado de las aerolíneas pues
necesitarías demasiado dinero para la
renta de la pista al aterrizar o la
compra de aviones y demás pero esto no
quiere decir que no puedas entrar pues
no hay una estipulación del gobierno que
diga no nadie más entra a este mercado
entonces más bien son barreras que
generan a lo mejor un poquito de
dificultad al entrar pero que no están
previendo entrar ahora yendo a nuestro
tercer punto de que no haya ventajas
aerolíneas que ya existen bien pues esto
algo tiene de cierto si inicia una
aerolínea mañana y estoy ofreciendo
realmente tasas comparables y un
servicio comparable podría imaginarme
que la gente estaría entrando a esto de
las aerolíneas con bastante frecuencia
entonces la industria de aerolíneas luce
bastante bien para nuestro punto
entonces ahora yendo a la buena
información de los precios y esto es
definitivamente bueno porque la
industria de las aerolíneas que es lo
que vino a mi mente pues no me puedo
imaginar una industria donde tuviéramos
un peor información que para las
aerolíneas pues tenemos ahora el
internet que es lo que existe y te ayuda
a saber los precios en cuanto al
transporte aéreo y si quieres viajar por
ejemplo del distritofederal a monterrey
puedes ir a cualquiera de las aerolíneas
por ejemplo volaris aeroméxico etcétera
y ver todos los vuelos que te convengan
en salidas y en lo que te convengan de
su precio ya que depende del precio del
que te convenga lo que puedas elegir y
de hecho ellos toman esto la gente lo
sabe y lo hace ellos toman un vuelo
y lo hacen por lo regular en si está en
cinco mil o seis mil pesos pero ellos
están buscando hasta que haya diferencia
hasta de centavos o en algunos cuantos
pesos para ahorrar lo que están
comprando por lo que esto es una buena
información y bastante abierta para el
público y quizá en este ejemplo no es
absolutamente la competencia perfecta
pero es un buen ejemplo para acercarnos
a tal descripción y ahora si nos vamos
en nuestra curva de oferta y demanda que
tenemos por acá este eje horizontal
estará representando la cantidad como
medida respecto al servicio de las
aerolíneas y este se mide respecto a los
billones de millas a cientos por semana
que es el número de asientos es el
número de asientos y sé que suena un
poco extraño pero es solamente lo que
está en una semana dada darnos todos los
asientos que están en uso y
multiplicarlo por dicho número de
asientos y entonces nos dan las millas
asientos en una semana entonces el
número de asientos mide la media de
millas por asientos en una semana dada y
luego por aquí en nuestro eje vertical
este sería el precio por millas asiento
y por supuesto que tiene que ver con la
curva de ofer
que tenemos por aquí esta es la curva de
oferta y primero para empezar a proveer
los primeros kilómetros o millas
las aerolíneas estarán dispuestas a
hacerlo de forma relativamente barata
tal vez ellos están descubriendo que los
aeropuertos más comunes donde la es tal
vez quizás más barato el aterrizaje o el
arrendamiento de dicho de dicho servicio
es en los más comunes pero como ellos
empezaron corriendo más y más rutas y
quizás entre ciudades cada vez más
pequeñas o tal vez con aviones menos
eficientes lo cual comenzaría con el
tiempo hacerse más y más caro para ellos
para poder ofrecer un incremento de sus
millas y obviamente del lado de la
demanda así un viaje en avión es muy
caro muy pocas personas van a querer
viajar entonces van a recurrir a muy
pocos viajes pero si es muy barato mucha
gente querrá viajar ahora digamos que
aquí es donde el mercado está ahora y
obviamente hay un punto de equilibrio
para el precio justo aquí y también
tendremos un punto de equilibrio para la
cantidad de millas asiento pero digamos
que el nivel del precio en orden en que
los competidores tienen de hecho su
ganancia económica
está por aquí así que este sea el precio
necesario para una ganancia económica de
0 la cual refleja un aparcamiento de
gastos de operación sin pérdidas o bien
puedes decirle también ganancia
económica neutral o ganancia normal es
la ganancia económica igual a 0 así que
dicho punto si es el precio luego
entonces las compañías que están
ofreciendo viajes aéreos están teniendo
una especie de neutralidad entre seguir
o dejar de ofrecer el servicio pero
observa la forma en como he dibujado
esto de aquí que es sustancialmente más
bajo que el precio de equilibrio actual
así que lo que estás diciendo es que
desde el punto de equilibrio actual que
era un poco más alto y bueno que este o
es simplemente superior que todos y
entonces estas compañías en el mercado
están generando ganancia económica
definitivamente una ganancia económica
muy positiva que es lo que es qué es lo
que está pasando bien si es ganancia
económica positiva quiere decir que hay
incentivos para otras compañías que
están entrando a la industria entonces
lo que va a pasar es que va a seguir
habiendo gente que quieran entrar
y seguido ofreciendo en el momento pero
tan pronto como otros se den cuenta que
esto puede pasar o que cualquiera de los
otros se dé cuenta que pueden ofrecer
más porque no siempre es necesario que
entren nuevas compañías pues puede haber
gente que ya existía dentro del mercado
y ofrezcan más pues quizás compren más
aviones o ofrezcan nuevas rutas pero tal
vez un poco después la oferta y la
oferta y la curva se vayan de esta forma
se vayan a tornar así y entonces luego
este sería nuestro nuevo precio de
equilibrio y así sucesivamente puede que
llegue un punto en el que sigan entrando
más personas y tenemos una nueva tercera
curva de oferta como es la que acaba de
mostrar aquí y un nuevo punto de
equilibrio un precio de equilibrio y
cómo te darás cuenta lo que está pasando
aquí es que nos estamos yendo hacia
abajo a lo largo de la curva de la
demanda conforme más oferta haya
obviamente estamos incrementando la
cantidad y el precio estaría bajando
pero todavía el precio de equilibrio es
mayor que esta línea de aquí entonces
más y más gente entrará antes de que
lleguemos a ese punto de aquí y este
punto justo este punto de aquí ahora es
el precio de equilibrio es justo donde
todos los competidores están para tener
la ganancia neutral o igual a cero y
aquí no hay incentivos para que nuevas
personas se entren a la industria pues
este precio de equilibrio está marcando
el punto neutro si no esto sería para
abajo y me gustaría dejar el vídeo por
aquí pues esto es lo que pasa con la
competencia perfecta y en los próximos
vídeos que voy a marcar nuevos
escenarios por ejemplo con un monopolio